[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry for leaving so long again
yeah we're back in minecraft world
everybody yeah
it's gaming monday yeah see ya yeah yeah
it's gaming
yeah i don't even remember how my house
works there's the door
yeah this is your house fan i built this
remember
[Music]
he loves it listen guys i have a tiny
bit of a dilemma
my minecraft is running in two frames
per second so sven do something
why is it so bad what am i doing wrong
that's better so here's the thing guys
we had an
amazing adventure sven we built
crazy structures that i'm genuinely
proud of
we have memories of jurgen smergen
we have a meatball right yeah we do have
a meatball
we have the boat of honor and cow
we beat the game like 600 times
right sven i don't know why i have cows
there i don't remember
we built the cake ladder we have alabama
lord of the underworld
right alabama
yes of course ikea bird of course
we built the sex chain uh torture i mean
we built this chamber for villagers
say
you did it and just like an overall
amazing experience
but for gaming month i know this is
going to hurt ola brittafita
i think it's time for me to take a break
i know and start a new world
yeah yeah new world called
now it's called niggly jabal
and it's in hardcore baby hardcore i
never beaten the game on hardcore before
and but i'm gonna do it we're doing it
live we're doing it live
smash like subscribe
hardcore
there we go
we'll find him my brand new
minecraft no one has ever done this
no one has ever said hey i'm gonna
create a new minecraft series
i'm the first we start with nothing
nothing baby
i feel so lost i feel so lonely how do i
play the game i don't
i just don't remember i think i'm
supposed to
say hi to cows and murder them
[Music]
how how cow how oh there we go
you gotta hit him in the titty sorry cow
uh i
i can milk milk you yeah i did a
markiplier meme that's right
anything can happen on gaming month i'm
going to beat a hardcore for those of
you don't know for some reason you're
like a minecraft noob or something
hardcore means if you die in hardcore
you die in real life that's right i am
attached to this electric chair
and if i die i die it's by pewdiepie
die yeah we're gonna build a new house
oh my god we're gonna build a new house
this brings me back man hey remember
knocking on woods with your
fists i do because it's epic
gaming mods i'm gonna speed run this
this will be one episode
look how fast i am my god how is he so
good at minecraft
and how is he so hands i don't know look
at that
look how fast i made that wood but no
one else can make wood this fast
all right so where should we put our
first
bees we got bees
i need a flower give me a flower this
will be my first companion in minecraft
i need a flower i need it
there there there there there there
there yes yes yes yes
yes yes i'm freaking out
we got bees his name will be
that's his name hey oh god he's so tall
hey
oh i love you
[Music]
all right you and me you're my new
friend uh
i'm gonna build your hou home a bee
house
don't leave don't leave me please
we're gonna build our house up high
hey hey oh jesus
come here yeah oh you're so no no no no
no
[Music]
hey god he's easily distracted
he's like a child like an actual
child all right come here
i place it there place it for you
go in go in go in
what i gotta do what i gotta do for you
go in seriously go in it's epic go in
you want a taller ceiling i got you oh
you want a taller scene
[Music]
okay
no no damn it you're a tricky one
how do you catch a bee i don't teach you
about this in school
seriously seriously
you're annoying me
are you so cute and stupid
no he's so smart my god he must take
after his father
me i birthed you it's safe trust me
trust me it's safe
dumb you're so dumb
[Music]
he's freaking out yeah
yeah dumb dumb dumb
all right so you stay here all right
stay in there no
all right fine fine
it's getting dark i need to i need to
build a house i need i need a house
okay see i remember in the brain
in my brain i remember yeah yeah yeah
we're done
we're done his pants dude cringe
uh all right so this is our house it
ain't much but it's on his house
[Music]
and now we're gonna build oh my god i'm
freaking out
i'm freaking out there we go we're good
speed run baby i think i saw some coal
somewhere
he is really following me isn't he we
reached stone age
i repeat no one's done it this fast
before i'm a minecraft veteran now
for real you know i play minecraft
before some of you kids were born
i need respect i played the alpha
y'all a bunch of betas all right i think
we got enough
but i'm gonna mine just add one yeah
yeah just i want it
just on one x just that one okay all
right
who needs jurgen when i got
damn i love my house it's so cozy
all right so now we got cold we can make
these but you didn't know that huh
yeah all right this is our mind
i guess we're building a stair god
have i beaten minecraft yet
i think i hate bedrock i've been digging
for so long
i dig straight down i don't even give a
[ __ ] when i'm done with that
[ __ ] i've been coming straight back up
cause um i'm
fully stacked diamond
[Laughter]
oh yeah for this full stack nether roar
another right whatever it's called i'm a
microphone i don't remember new things
all right the goal this episode is to
get diamond
that's the goal we found it that's
diamond
using granite
like jack would say a bunch of shots
yeah why have i not found diamond yet
this is [ __ ]
i remember in my first playthrough i
found like a skeleton spawner
right away next to my base and i never
found one ever since
i searched everywhere for another
spawner but never found
one and it hurts to this day so if we
can find
yeah we'll find a bunch of stuff in this
world this world will be different look
how much stuff i'm finding
how do i check i'm on 62.
yeah soon
[Laughter]
soon we'll get the truck god this is
gonna take forever
[Music]
did i ever tell you guys that my first
video ever was actually a minecraft
video
i think i said this before but maybe you
don't know about it i
i've been searching oh iron hell yeah
i've been searching for it but it's gone
forever it was hilarious
i got scared by skeletons in the cave
and screamed
minecraft is scary the first time you
play it's terrifying i don't know man
but uh i sent it to machinima because i
thought i was like
oh maybe minecraft will be a big popular
game maybe i should everyone's playing
call of duty
maybe maybe i could be one of those
minecraft channels
yeah yeah i thought about that big brain
but i thought it was so weird like i'm i
don't have any subscribers i have zero
subscribers like who am i talking to
like right now i'm talking to you guys i
have an audience yeah i swear i do
trust me but then i was like well i need
an audience so maybe if i send it to
like another channel they can like
post it and then it will be like i'm
addressing someone and that way it won't
be so weird
because back in the day was actually
weird doing what i'm doing right now now
it's perfectly normal right
but luckily i actually hit bedrock are
you serious
oh my god well luckily things worked out
fine anyway
how do i beat minecraft i forgot i need
ender pearls
i need another round yeah i know how to
beat minecraft of course
yeah this is so lame
oh my god we got redstone this is
incredible
oh you need an iron pickaxe i didn't
know that i mean i knew that
[ __ ] jesus that scared me
oh my god oh my god i finally found
something
holy sh oh we could definitely find what
is that
what is that that's stone what is that
ah
all right i gotta go we're gonna explore
this first i need to check on my best
friend in the whole world
after sven of course i don't know it
feels really good to have a new
level it feels feels fresh i like it
uh oh yeah now i'm gonna make one of
these you guys probably don't know about
it but it's a furnace
you can actually use this a pro
minecraft tip
uh to smelt iron
yeah all right let's murder some cows
hey
where'd he go maybe we should pluck some
flowers and put them next to our house
so
we'll come
oh god i cannot defend myself against
tall
uh man i actually can't mess around now
god damn he took my blog
god damn my house is beautiful let's put
some flowers
actually you guys probably don't know
about this but you can actually
uh make two furnaces and then you could
twice
as faster use yeah
yeah subscribe for more minecraft tips
guys
um oh i'm gonna i can make some armor
now right
i know them all in head get it i made a
helmet
what the [ __ ] is that how do i make leg
what
armor has got to be like this right
what i know i know how to make it don't
worry about it guys
hey hey hey
hey hey yup
what's up get out of my house get out of
my property
i have no friends hey
why is there nothing in my biome except
that ladies
thing damn it beautiful
welcome to my house i'm so lonely
honestly this is so sad
i am so lonely
i need someone to hold me
[Music]
she
what a sheep
wait they wheat right hey sheep
you want some wheat come here
please i have no friends please please
don't
don't make me do this that's for water
sheep you dumb [ __ ]
dude this biome [ __ ] sucks dude oh
there's a honey thing here
all right my house is a little hard to
find so i'm gonna
do a little trick-a-roo
[Music]
is anyone out there i need a friend
help
ah oh god the sun is setting guys
i still have no friends it's still too
close to home get it because we're home
okay i guess i'll we'll have that we'll
head down
yeah that's how i wanted to build that
thank you
yeah that's thank you minecraft
i built the stairway it goes all the way
up
are you serious oh my god
there we go ha now i can mine you
unlocked yeah making achievements left
and right
all right we got a new tunnel i'm
stacked iron but we got to be careful
why is there like no enemies or nothing
am i playing on like peaceful or
something
versus baby mode i thought this was
supposed to be hardcore
is this the mode babies plaque huh let's
not fall in the lava
gold
yes first episode
let's go told you bro i told you i'm a
pro
easy peasy squeeze my teeth
yeah la pizzazzuli my gamer
give me that goal can you mine gold with
the iron pickaxe
i have bad food
yeah fine
i don't die oh my god i cannot make
moves like that
give me that give me that yeah oh two
oh he made two of them oh
yes yes am i that poor
i don't uh all right we're just gonna do
a quick scan
quick scan i know i'm low on health and
i shouldn't risk it
but you gotta take risks when you're
playing hardcore minecraft
trust me on this one guys this feels
like a bad idea
but that's how good ideas are born all
right we'll make a lava bridge
see no problem
huh
yes yes yes yes oh no no no no no no no
no
no no no no no no no no no no
all right let's build safety nets around
them oh god it's a creeper
that could actually kill me what do i do
oh god i'm actually low on health
uh creeper can you not seriously this is
my first
hardcore playthrough i just found
diamond
uh let's be real here let's be cool
thanks man
you're a real g
see we're taking it safe we're taking it
slow i'm a minecraft veteran now and
i made the mistakes i made in the past
and i'm not making them again
wait where'd i come from there i came
from there
no we're playing hardcore
that scared me sven xenon skate
wait wait a minute wait a minute if i
have a diamond pickaxe i could
i can get the the bling blong
yeah i can get this right
ice bucket challenge oh god i have that
stupid name
god damn it
no no oh my god he actually hit me a
little bit
one creeper and i'm done not happening
not happening she i'm so scared
where are you good
it's raining it's raining
i don't have any food i'm poor all right
if i
even nudge the ground i'm dead
i'm better than dead i'm done please i
think i
just eat
with them cows at oh that feels good i'm
rejuvenation
this feels so dramatic this is the most
dramatic farming that has ever been done
there we go okay oh it's a cute little
bunny
it's a cute little bunny my only friend
the bunny funny
dead you're so dead you're so dead yeah
dead no me
he died for nothing well fellas
we got diamond yeah oh i only got eight
all right next time in next episode
we're gonna find a friend
i hope smash like subscribe for more
epic minecraft to pros and tips
this has been episode place your bets
how many episodes we're gonna last
if i die it's over let's get it
thanks for watching brofist
for some high level gaming gear check
out face
okay but of what top scientists have
determined
that wearing base gear makes you a
better gamer with at least
two percent basis for everyone no matter
what level you're at but you need to be
at least six
eight to order which i am of course you
have before
december 11th to place your order and
solidify your place
in the gaming history booths so what are
you waiting for
buff up your wardrobe today and head
over to base.gg
basil i'm 68 i swear
in high order